Film Courage: Does a network require that
you submit an outline before writing?
Christine Conradt: Sometimes.
It depends on the exec that you’re working
with and it depends on the producer.
Sometimes the producer will require it.
Sometimes it’s just we go from one paragraph
to one page.
Sometimes we go from one paragraph to a script,
whatever they want, whatever makes them feel
comfortable in their process is what I deliver
to them.
Film Courage: What’s the typical show that
you’re writing for, the length of time?
Christine Conradt: That is takes me to write
it?
Film Courage: What would be the typical air-time?
Christine Conradt: For most television, it’s
83 to 86 minutes for a feature.
Film Courage: Then what does that translate
into in terms of pages?
Christine Conradt: It depends on the producer
in terms of pages.
So you know sort of the standard is one page
equals one minute of screen time.
That’s sort of a loose guide.
I have a producer I work with who won’t
shoot anything under 116 pages because he
likes to have a lot of footage to cut down
to help the pacing.
I have other producers I work with who they
don’t want anything over a hundred pages.
So it depends on their production process.
Film Courage: Interesting.
So I’m really getting the sense that it’s
all about flexibility.
Christine Conradt: It is all about flexibility.
Yes!
Being flexible is definitely a help.
And again, giving them what they want.
When I ask producers “Why do you fire writers?”
I ask every producer I’ve worked with “Why
do you fire writers?”
And they will always say “Because they don’t
give me what I ask them to give me.”
So either notes they’ve given and the writer
comes back and they haven’t done that with
the notes because they thought they knew better
or they just didn’t know how.
Or they asked for a certain page count and
it wasn’t that page count.
To me, those are the wrong reasons to get
fired off of a project.
Those are things you can control.
So if you’re just paying attention and asking
them what they want and they want to tell
you what they want.
I ask “What do you want your page lengths
to be here?
Where do you want your act lengths to be?”
And then that’s what I give them.
Film Courage: So what’s the time frame that
you’re usually given?
Once they’ve given you the title, you’ve
met with them, you’ve come up with some
ideas, what time frame are you working with?
Christine Conradt: It depends.
Typically I get 4 weeks for a first draft
and then two weeks for every subsequent draft,
which is pretty quick actually.
It’s not that difficult if you’re only
working on one project at a time but if you’re
a working writer you’re working on multiple
projects because it takes so long before one
of them suddenly comes back and says “Okay,
we’re greenlit.
We can actually move forward.”
You don’t know when that’s going to happen.
So you’ve got all these sort of irons in
the fire and then eventually one will come
back and sometimes two come back, which is
great.
But now you have to balance how you are going
to deliver both of those scripts.